wow bienvenue à paris et merci d'avoir
apporté
ce conte de fées là où nous en avons besoin
bien nous venons de découvrir des
scènes incroyables des
films alors en gros combien pouvez-vous
nous dire sur
votre personnage
et peut-être le plaisir de
revisiter
jusqu'à
euh je pense euh
je pense que c'était à la fois le plus grand
plaisir et un défi extrême
un tel original extraordinaire
toujours mon principe préféré j'ai
identifié
le meilleur juste parce que le
rose était ma couleur préférée et elle
portait toujours la robe et avait de
longs cheveux blonds et j'avais le long
cheveux blonds donc elle était
ma princesse
tant de fois auparavant mais je l'ai regardé
juste avant de recommencer à filmer
je voulais m'assurer que je lui
apportais ça parce que je suis tellement
fan
des fans vous deux la lumière  et l'
obscurité et aussi la grande chimie pourriez-
vous nous parler un peu de votre
relation et comment lentement mais
sûrement vous avez construit cela à l'écran
pour tout expliquer sur notre
relation
bu  t la bonne chose à ce sujet est que
vous savez tellement
cette histoire que nous sommes revenus sur la
façon dont nous nous affectons les uns les autres et donc
je pense que
c'est un beau scénario
n'était pas seulement pour divertir les enfants
ou pour raconter une histoire le but était de  essayez
de voir si
ces
mots mots chers journalistes alors qui a lancé
la première question ici où est le micro
journaliste
salut marque segos magazine
écran vert et effets spéciaux
pouce
devait faire ça et aussi juste en utilisant votre
imagination d'une manière
imaginez
parce que je ne suis pas
tout  était un peu maladroit mes vêtements
tout se sentait assez
gênant et puis j'ai effrayé mes propres
enfants
il y a quelques choses qui devaient être
réglées peu importe
quand vous avez tout ensemble, il vous
suffit de prendre une profonde respiration et de dire d'accord
je
Je vais bien, je veux dire, le film original de Disney,
je veux dire, était comme une base pour vous ou avez-
vous vraiment essayé de vous en éloigner, pour ainsi
dire, à
la fois
est devenu une nouvelle découverte
et ce qui s'est passé en
essayant d'obtenir ce centre ri  ght et
précisément
c'est
bien tu es
bien sûr assez méchante mais très charmante
en même temps et tu sembles
révéler dans ta méchanceté ou ta méchanceté
en tant qu'actrice où es-tu allé au fond de toi
ou pas pour découvrir la cruauté en
toi
oh my
huh
il y a quelque chose d'étrange à jouer
le méchant là où c'est le cas
et je pense que nous avons tous quelque chose dedans,
nous avons tous de la méchanceté en nous et nous avons tous des
définitions, nous nous retrouvons tous peut-être
sur le chemin du trafic, vous êtes
frustré
rien qu'en les tirant  tous ensemble et
pouvoir en rire,
mais ce n'est pas comme ce genre de
drame lourd avec le drame que les choses sont à
peu près lourdes sous les problèmes très graves
,
eh bien, vous venez de mentionner plus tôt que la
première fois que vos enfants vous ont vu en fait,
ils étaient en quelque sorte  peur,
je veux dire, comment leur avez-vous en quelque sorte parlé
du personnage, qu'est-ce que vous leur avez montré pour les
rendre un peu moins effrayés, pour ainsi
dire, je les ai amenés à elle, bien sûr,
la belle au
bois dormant et c'est pourquoi vous méritez  euh
et peut-être que c'était la révélation
qu'elle avait quelque chose que
vous ne pouviez pas tout à fait
comprendre
bien félicitations d'abord pour ce que nous avons
vu ce matin je veux dire angela vous êtes
tous les deux ici évidemment une actrice mais aussi
productrice exécutive qu'est-ce que cela a apporté
au film donc à  parlez ou à quel point
avez-vous dû voir ce
film des deux points de vue
euh pour être honnête, ce n'était pas très difficile
dans aucun film dont vous faites partie, essayez de
participer à notre niveau,
est-ce que votre personnage est vraiment vraiment
cruel ou est-elle  essayant vraiment de
se lever et de défendre un territoire qui
est adressé par des êtres humains
oui elle est je pense que je pense que vous trouverez
qu'il y a beaucoup plus
que cette idée est elle est elle
et s'en prend à un enfant innocent
qu'elle perd  son humanité
quand elle est petite, elle a un
sens très fort du fait qu'elle protège
la terre
la question
bonjour